[Music]
on television they tell you that every
episode of every show is a very special
episode well in the hundreds of episodes
of the Reuben report I've actually never
said this is a special episode until
today
joining me is lubed Achmed a free
thinker and chemical engineering student
who has spent her entire life in Iraq
lube mill was a guest on the Reuben
report about two years ago via Skype but
right after our talk Ludo was subjected
to death threats and had to go into
hiding after two long years Lubner has
finally made it to the United States and
now today I welcome my new friend into
my home and into my studio lube nach med
welcome to the Reuben report thank you
for having me again and I'm very
grateful to you and for all the people
who helped in my case and for all who
had seen my first interview and you know
come to conclusion to think about things
again and about situations and you know
in my country and other countries around
in the Middle East yeah so thank you and
um I'm grateful welcome to all of you
know tell of years ago yeah
well I think a lot of people are
grateful to you to for having the
bravery to tell your story and and be
open be who you are even come here now I
mean the other one we did was was two
years ago and at the we reposted that a
few days ago so people have seen that
already hopefully if they're watching
this right now but when we did that
interview two years ago you had reached
out to me and I didn't know I didn't
know if you were legit I didn't know if
this was some sort of hoax or something
but then we Skyped privately and you
told me your story and then I talked to
my friend Faisal who obviously was from
Iraq too and then he talked to you on
the phone and he basically said to me
that if I won't talk to you
and that you're an adult and you have
capacity over your mind and can make
your own decisions that if I won't talk
to you that nobody will talk to you and
that you'll never get any help and
that's why we decided to do it
did you think that after we spoke that
it was gonna get so bad so quickly I
didn't think so actually back that time
I was more into talking I want I wanted
my my voice to be heard to the other
people around because situations in my
country are bad and for you know people
like me you know I'm good I have a you
know a very good family I was raised in
a in a very free space but there are
millions of people in my country they
have no rights they have no space to
even to think about themselves
so it was important for me to share my
story and to share my thoughts so the
other the other side of the world can
get you know a view and an image to what
are the situations in my country and
especially for women
because as you seen after 2003 when bad
and especially for women and for
children so for myself as an educated
person I was so you know I was abused
and treated badly in my society from my
people and you know by my religion so it
was very important for me to speak up
yeah how come it was so important for
you to show your face in the interview
because I remember when we talked
originally I said you know if you want
to wear a mask if you want us to blur
your face out and you said no I want
people to see me because because it's
very important for me see in York all
all kind of all kinds of people are they
have the right to to have their faces to
have their full identity without fear
you have the militias a groups in York
Hezbollah Dawa has been Sahar ocotilla
Hezbollah they you know they come up to
people with their faces
their identities and you have the other
side the terrorists in Iraq as well they
act you know freely in the country but
for people like me you know I didn't
hurt anyone I didn't you know treat
anyone in a bad way so why should I hide
my my identity I mean it's very
important for me to declare Who I am
because everyone has the right to
declare who they are and and and in what
they do believe in for me it's very
important to say that I am an atheist
because in my country everyone is
calling that we are Muslims we are
Sydney's we are Shia and we practice
what we want but for me it became in the
recent years very important to share my
thoughts yeah you mentioned that you
were brought up in a free space so your
mom who actually now is with you in the
United States you guys got here together
and you're living with your sister who
had moved here years before but although
you have two brothers interacts tonight
so your mom basically created a free
space for you to be able to think and
write you told me that you were reading
books by Sam Harris and Richard Dawkins
people that hopefully I'll be able to
introduce you to at some point because
because she's actually an atheist I mean
she started to think about religion from
an early age so she didn't go up in a
you know in our logistic space although
that you know her family were you know
it stricted with her you know but for
her she always thought that she's an
atheist and she tried to to raise you
know her children to be not atheist but
to think for themselves to have their
brain to work out because we were born
without knowing what is God is or what
are religions but we you know brought to
this world to our societies
the idea of God and the idea of
religions was forced into us for me I
didn't know what was God is until I you
know got to high school and you know we
have a classes that teaches Islamic you
know lessons till at that point I
started to realize what is God and you
know and what Islam is so my mom she I'm
very grateful to her because she's I
think she's my God for me huh that's the
yeah yeah this is what I think and what
I do believe in yeah that's a beautiful
thing yeah
it's interesting you talked so much
about why showing your face was
important all these all these bad people
basically get to show their face of them
and then the good people are the ones
that are shamed into it I always talk
about how I get so much email from
people in America a free society that
are afraid to say what they think while
living here which I'm sure is
mind-blowing to you like we don't really
understand the freedoms that we have
yeah I don't know but I mean America is
the land that I think it's magical it
you know it is fun and to protect the
freedom so how come people in here can
you know afraid to show their faces or
to share their ideas or their thoughts I
can understand that but for me I just
want to say something they won't they
might you know want to live one day 24
hours in my country I think that that's
the point that maybe make them try to
think deeply and the rights and the
freedom they have that I and people in
my country don't have any Ark everything
is is tracked you are not yourself in
Middle East in general you had to be
forced into something you had to be
afraid you have to
afraid of who you are you don't know
what you are or who you are until you
die but in the United States from what
you know I've been here six months so I
can see that sometimes I don't feel that
I you know I belong here because I do
miss a lot of things that I used to do
in my country but in other words you
know I enjoy the freedom that I have now
and I'm grateful to the United States of
America it's a very great nation and the
principles and the concepts this country
was built on is I think he's a
humanitarian principles from what I
learned about the history of United
States and I hope all the people and
American I think in in the Western world
and even in my countries get to see this
history so they can learn and they can
build we can build that you know the
future for the next generation we have
yeah it's so nice to hear you say that
because we do forget it here you know
and that's that's why when you reached
out to me that I thought this is
something this is a person who's
fighting for the same things that we're
fighting for here our fight is so much
easier and you were willing to put
yourself out there all right so we do
that interview two years ago and then I
think within almost 24 hours maybe two
days yeah you contacted me and said that
there were Hsieh militias basically that
had either seen the video or had gotten
word of the video and that you were in
trouble and then we had sort of spotty
communication for a couple months and
there were a few other people that tried
to help I know some people that watch
the show were raising funds to help get
you to a safe house and all that but can
you just sort of tell me about those
first few weeks I know your dealer
really was for almost two years but what
was that initial part when you heard
that people knew about what you
it well I was afraid not you know for
myself but for my family although I
asked my mom and you know if I can do
that you know I had the permission but I
was afraid for my family I didn't you
know I wasn't afraid for myself that
much to me quite honest because I mean
this is a case that if you're if I said
yes so I have to take the
responsibilities for that but basically
I was afraid for my mother and mainly so
it was very you know what happened yeah
how did you hear like what was the first
thing that you heard that somebody was I
went to the college actually and I saw
papers you know threats my name was
written on it and it says that death to
the atheists in Iraq that to you and I
took the paper and I turned that tear it
down and I went out of the college and
that's when I actually contacted you and
all the people because a lot of the
people in my community so that interview
and around my university and you know
the nearby universities actually they
even shared their thoughts on the
Richard Dawkins foundation some of this
students oh right because the the
Dawkins foundation had also posted the
video that we did so the video was going
along place and then it was hard we took
the video down but copies had been made
and we tried to contact everybody to get
all the copies taken down when did it
kind of escalate past that like did
anyone actually say a direct threat to
you in that initial yeah yeah a lot of
told me that you will go to hell we will
kill you eventually but did people know
you were an atheist before that I mean I
assume as a as a chem
engineer yeah community yeah yeah and my
college they knew because you know I had
a lot of discussions I mean I can't keep
my mouth I'm sorry shot yeah
I defined in America yeah I do speak and
I what you know every time I you know I
listen to them talk you know delusional
things I had to say something so I was
none for my thoughts and I shared a lot
of articles actually or I thinks in a
lieutenant BC treat by my name but I
didn't put my full name on it but I did
you know separate papers my name on it
just to say my thoughts the same I you
know I used to share my thoughts on
Facebook I used to always opposed verses
of Quran and you know explain it to my
friends American friends and other
people so I was known for you know for
being atheist and I faced a lot of
threats actually before the show
physical threats against me I was you
know once it slapped on the way my home
from my college actually by a guy in the
car and so and I was attacked several
times in my college so I was always done
so that's why I decided to go and you
know because it's there is no point of
you know keeping it silent for me I had
to speak up so yeah I can see it in you
I know you couldn't even if you tried to
not say what what do you think well I
don't know but for me it was important
and I think I want to say that American
people should now read their history
again and remind themselves that what
they have is very great I can't even
describe it in words
they should learn more about it and they
should protect the freedom because
America is you know for all of us for
all of the people who had their rights
gone who don't have any you know hold on
have any rights in their countries I do
think that it is very important to fight
for this country and to stop the Islam
disease to get into it this is very
important for me now so so alright so
suddenly you saw the the letters at
school people were saying things to you
yeah I remember we were trading some
emails and sometimes you didn't have
internet for days and you were moving
around and things yeah kind of tell me
what happened over the next couple
months you were put in a safe house for
a while I know at one point we had some
people that were trying to get you maybe
to the Kurdish regional area because
it's more western friendly there and
there are more Americans there what was
that whole year I went into I think I
moved around
I changed the places a lot how does that
even happen like how do you make the
contacts to know that you're going to a
place that's safe because I didn't know
I just moved around i disguised actually
to be quite honest I didn't go with my
phony face because I would be recognized
but I said meaning you were wearing the
hijab Italian yeah Wow yeah that's how
did that feel for you just knowing
everything with you well I felt nothing
to be quite honest and I'm coward at the
at the end because I do believe that if
you are if you believe in something you
would do it too the last thing that's
right but I pad because maybe because of
the positive feedback
I received maybe because I believe that
although that I'm a very tiny person and
and you know and that there are lots of
you know worse cases than mine but I
thought maybe I can stay alive and share
my my experience with a lot of people so
I think that's what drove me to put a
job and to disguise that just to save
you know my life and to be able to speak
up again yeah but other than that I
don't feel that to be quite honest um
special or or anything it's just um I'm
coward and I I lost the passion I used
to have back in my country now I sense
that maybe a new passion will be I don't
know we'll be starting while you're here
I don't know I used to put myself into
things I think you're doing that right
now and you know I was a stopped by a
lot of you know army soldiers there are
key soldiers for trying to take pictures
of some of the establishment for like
Harrogate Ansar Allah it's in Arabic
there is something like Hezbollah ok
yeah I tried to take some pictures of
their building so I can post it online
and I was started by some of the Iraqi
you know soldiers they told me this
dangerous to take that and they took my
iPad and delete the pictures but I get
the chance I got the chance to post it
it and keep carving my friend yeah he
posted that so for me I do put myself
into things not because I love troubles
no it's just because I wanted you know
share a view of the country that maybe
you didn't see get to see because I
a lot of reporting things they don't
tell you the whole truth about Iraq but
for me you know I can't tell you the
truth so yeah yeah I hope in the future
I might you know change my views I don't
know for now but hopefully yeah well you
just got here yeah you're just getting
your feet wet so to speak so you
mentioned Keith there's there's a couple
other people who we both know that I
don't know that they want to be
mentioned publicly so I'm just not gonna
mention names even though they all did a
lot of yeah a lot of good things but
what was it like to be in communication
with people a crow I mean there were
people literally across the world that
we're trying to help you as you were
yeah running it must have that must have
given you like some a little extra
glimmer of hope or something right yeah
and there are you know special people to
me I can't say names but one person who
put hoping you know in me and uh you
know I believed in him for several
nights I you know I even missed my own
voice I didn't speak I didn't say
anything I was alone and one person who
kept me alive and you know all I owe him
my life actually to be quite honest and
were you with your mom the entire time
that this was all happening from the
beginning now but at some point she got
into with me because she phased try it's
about me so she had to be with me
actually
so um I'm grateful to that person
particular one and all the people who
helped in my case and especially I'm
very grateful to you
I can't I'm grateful to you get the
moment that we talked and and you are a
friend and you're a family for me now so
yeah I'm very grateful to you and
thankful tn all the
people yeah David yeah well I'm grateful
for you two because this is what it's
all about you you're doing something
that right this very second you're doing
something that this is what people need
this is what people need to understand
if as you're saying if we're gonna
protect the things that are great about
this country when we have to hear from
people like you yeah and and the fact
that you were so brave in a place you
know we have people that aren't brave
while they're free and you're brave in a
place where you learn it free it's
incredibly inspired because the
situation's Drive you to because you you
have you don't have the right to be who
you are it's you know a kind of and.and
you know believing in yourself can drive
you to be to talk and to be who you are
for me it's very important from what I
learned about you know nature about size
it's very important to shape who you are
because every one of us has a unique
personality we don't have to be the same
we don't have to follow others to be a
picture of others or if I reflect as you
can say so for me it's very important to
share that with you people and for you
to protect this you know free space so
we can be creative that's what matters
for me yeah so all right let's get I
want I want to get to you're part of
your life in America so how did okay so
you bounced around from these safe safe
houses basically when did you get a call
or where were you when you realize that
actually you could get out because in
the midst of all of this by the way it
was everything happening with this
supposed the Trump travel ban and Iraq
wasn't on the list I guess it maybe is
on I'm not even sure right now where the
list I'm not even sure where that whole
thing stands at the moment actually but
I remember thinking and then we had lost
communication for a while and I had
reached out to some other people and
they didn't know where you were and this
whole thing but when did it actually you
start getting some signs that
right well it's um early and I think in
august-september from the people that
were in touch with me yeah so this is
lasso a little over a year ago yeah
2016 yeah and I was contacted by other
people through my email that I might
have an interview with you know for an
immigration status or something and it
does you know started and I managed to
go and do that actually it was hard for
me but you know I did it basically
because since I told you I disguise so
sometimes it easy for me to move this
you know disguised and I did it and I
think in in the last year but after the
travel ban everything has ended in
earlier in 2017 but another way so
basically you got in because you started
the process before the band yes yeah
yeah and then you know these people
helped me trying to do the humanitarian
parole visa and it you know I got it so
yeah I'm here yeah and we can't mention
that you mentioned Richard Dawkins
before you'll find in America there's a
certain subset of people who
unfortunately say terrible things about
him and say he's an islamaphobe in all
of this nonsense
but the Center for inquiry which is his
organization yeah not only facilitated
some of that but it's helping you with
some legal stuff right now yeah yeah
yeah they're helping me I mean actually
they supported me with a few you know
amount of money and they supported my
case with the lawyers so I can't say no
more about that but ultimately I'm I'm
very grateful to mr. Richard Dawkins
because he he takes his words into
actions not like others because
he sees that it is very important to
save people you know who are like me I'm
not special but people in general you
know who do believe in themselves who do
believe in atheism it isn't it's not
about you know not believing in God
I mean religion is as a personal a
practice you don't have to declare your
religion I mean it's just between you
and the thing you are believing in it
but nowadays I think it's important to
declare who we are because of the you
know the Islamic stuff is going on
around the separating of religion Islam
that's the point that you know makes you
wonder that I should you know declare my
thoughts or you know to get it to to the
other people so anyway they helped me in
my case and I'm grateful for him and
hopefully one day I get to see him I
will I will do the best I can for
whatever that's yeah and I'm very
thankful to you can do that yeah yeah
you never have to thank me again that's
for the record so what was it like the
day that you did someone call you and
say you're you're gonna get out I mean
did they bring you in and talk to you
like what was that moment like um yeah I
was communicating through emails
actually because internet was not I
don't I didn't have internet all the
time you know I'm moving around but it
was you know I was lucky to get my email
opened before you know one day I think
from from the interview with the in the
US Embassy in Baghdad mm-hmm I didn't
get the chance to open my email so one
day before the interview I get to see an
email from the embassy that I have
interviewed the next day huh
so yeah was very quick and
when actually to the interview and the
Consul was very nice
he spoke Arabic actually and you just
saw me and he said okay you have this
I'll get your passport and you have to
see when once you get to United States
you can you know have your case or your
no visa to be you know changed that's
the point that I didn't feel anything to
be quite honest it's just them because
because of the whole situation I've been
through I can't feel that I'm happy I'm
sad it's just something like that I
thought was normal
if I'm gonna be admitted or not it will
be fine but did they tell you at that
time that your mom could come with you
yeah she came with me yeah but you knew
so immediately they said yeah how soon
after that interview did you get out
well about 10 10 days I was out like
those 10 days I was I don't know how to
I didn't believe it actually thought I
get here because even at the airport I
was with my mom stopped for half-hour we
were isolated from the other passengers
I was very afraid actually because I I
took I you know I showed me my whole
face so we were stopped and the passport
were taken from us for a half hour and I
said I remember I sat there and I
realized that this is maybe my last
moment I didn't I didn't believe that I
will leave Rock actually but after half
hour they came and they gave us the
passports and they said
you have a very rare visa how did you
get it well and I don't think we can get
you on the you know on the plane I
couldn't believe that so but soon after
that another officer came he was from
Jordan because my travel was from York
to Jordan and then from the United
States
so he said ok we will let you in but you
had to have a return that visa you know
mm-hmm but for now you can go so after
that I was relieved yeah so then you get
to Jordan and from there you get on the
plane to the United States yeah I don't
want to say where your sister lives but
you're now living with your sister in
the United States yeah what was that
moment when you stepped off the plane
what was that like I cried yeah
I didn't know what to feel it's just I
cried and actually I I fall down I
couldn't walk and I was hugging my mom
at that moment and at that moment I I
felt that I'm alive again to be quite
honest that you know and I didn't lose
my life and though I lost my passion up
there but I got the chance to tell my
story that I'm not you know I'm not dead
but other than that I was fine with me
actually yeah it's so interesting
because you you've said this thing about
losing your passion or you don't know
what to feel and I can only
after after everything you've been
through but yet you came to do this you
wanted to do this when you contacted me
and said I'm here you said I want to do
this and I want to share my story and
all that so right there to me that's
like enough of like a little ember of
fire that shows that you have it Wow
I don't know but for me I do consider
myself I lost it because once you are
out of the situation in in a country
that you feel yourself when you are out
and doing things and speak and and do
all these things I do feel that you know
this is my my personality in there you
know I get to talk with people I get to
you know to pay things and say that or
you know and I get to be annoyed body
some leashes and yeah right believe me I
do feel that passion for me yeah but
from what you are saying it is
passionate from your point yes one is
you know do that to just you know tell
people please do not you know surrender
do not you know give it up it's not too
late we can you know fight and we can
win it we can protect the freedoms and
we can protect the next generation what
matters for me the next you know
generation because now we are done with
you know you can't teach 20 years old
women or men or maybe 40 years old to
leave for example Islam to forget these
ideas still have as a human being I
can't for me because they are convinced
that Islam is the most perfect religion
and all the people around the world
should be Muslims in the end so my main
focus is the next generation I don't
want to go too deep into the religion
part because I think your story is so
powerful in and of itself but do you
think that the religion
can be reformed from the inside because
I know that there's a big conversation
and I've talked to a lot of the people
on both sides of it some people who say
Islam has to just be left all together
and choose atheism or choose another set
of beliefs altogether secularism or even
another religion and then there's
another group of people that say no it
can be reformed Christianity was
reformed most religions go through some
kind of reformation
well the Reformation is a delusion I
don't believe in it because but a lot of
people now doing their Reformation
actually it's not Reformation is
transformation Reformation for me it
does not exist because you have verses
and a book you believe it is written by
God so how could you reform verses that
is in Quran written by God you are
admitting yourself this is not a perfect
religion your God is not perfect and
number two you are admitting that there
is no such a god you are kafir this is
what Islam is all about if you this obey
what is in Quran any word of it you are
careful you are infidel unbeliever so
the Reformers who are trying to reform
verses are trying to say that for
example ithi ISM is not punished by
death or the gay are not punished by you
know death our stuff this is not true I
mean there are direct verses to say gays
you know they they deserve the death and
infidels as well so how can you inform
that and there are verses to attack the
Christians and the Jews how could you do
that I mean this is nonsense the
Reformation itself is nonsense from
a transformation what they are doing now
is trying to you know to put a perfect
image for Islam this Psalm is not a
perfect religion it's not even a
religion it's a political ideology set
by Mohammed Mohammed was a genius back
his time he studied the you know the old
religions because basically a religion
is you know it came from Judaism we
didn't know anything about religions
basically but he studied that I do
believe in that he studied all these
things and he put it in Quran he said he
put the juicy stories the Christian
stories and corn and the different part
was the additional part was his
historian a crown
there is nothing different about Quran
except Muhammad's story and what he did
so all the talk about Islam can be
reformed is nonsense but you can't leave
Islam yes you can't leave Islam you
can't practice Islam you can't practice
it but you will end up like Isis because
I do believe that a good Muslim who is
you know following Islam and be just
like Muhammad a bad Muslim who are the
majority of Muslims who do not know how
to pray they don't have what is Islam
all about they don't know even what
isn't crown or hadith or anything about
that and the ugly side of Muslims who
are the people who know about Islam but
they don't speak they don't share their
their ideas so for me for me I want
people and and all these what I call
them I'm sorry bad Muslims to leave
Islam because they are atheist to be
quite honest with you every time I speak
to them they don't believe in what's in
car
they sometimes laugh you know we do
laughs mm-hmm but they follow all takea
it is you know I'll take it it is
something you act in front of the
majority people so for me I do think
that all these bad Muslims can leave
Islam and be idiots and they can't
practice anything they want
just leave Islam because Islam is all
about submission it's all about you know
forcing others to to be actually to be
slaves and it is it is not the religion
of peace Muhammad is not a peaceful man
I mean he killed a book he was a 120
years old Jew man who you know who was
against Muhammad he didn't attack
Muhammad with sword he only said this is
not you know a religion Muhammad is a
liar he killed him and he killed a woman
as a small bit bit bent Marwan she was
sitting with sleeping with her children
and he said one of his men to kill her
he killed even Abdullah bin saud
Abdullah bin Said was interesting
because Abdullah one said how did he how
did how how he became unbeliever in
Muhammad he used to write for Muhammad
Muhammad you know when Gabrielle came to
him and he told him all the verses about
you know and you know they talk about
and kraan so Muhammad used to have
people to write for him he was spoken
you know the Angels right spoke to
Muhammad so can he can translate all
these verses to the other people who
used to write for him so abdullah bin
Saud he used to write for Muhammad and
he a lot of you know books on
that a beloved said tried to change some
words when he is tried for Mohammed to
get to see Muhammad if he can notice
that he changed yeah he was the
first-ever copy yeah exactly
but Muhammad didn't change that did it
sorry didn't notice that Abdullah bin
bin said changed some you know words or
anything and sometimes it says another
you know or Francis or books it said
that Abdullah bin Said and others
suggested some ideas to Muhammad to put
in Quran so abdullah bin said when he
saw that he became unbeliever he said
this is all here you know all Muhammad's
work so for me all the talk about
Reformation to get you to the point yeah
I don't believe in it and I do and I
don't want people to feel for that you
know you just don't believe in it
Christianity was reformed the church the
Catholic Church actually reformed not
the the you know the book or the rules
in the book now people changed reform
the Christianity because why because
they left it you know they practice
their lives and you know anything they
want to think about right yeah well
that's the thing most people who
practice religion even who considered
themselves religious actually or secular
they have some you know traditional
values or some memories positions or or
things like that
all right let's not go too far next time
you come on because I think this is
gonna be just the first of many times
that we do this cuz yeah I think there's
so many great things in your future I
know it actually so let's talk about
what it's been like to live in America
little bit so like you get to your
sisters you know I'm sure the first
couple of days all the emotion stuff but
wasn't like to like go out for the first
time where what you want cut your hair
the way you want to all of that like
what's it been like well I think it's
well it was very amazing for me you know
just to go out and not being you know a
tagged I'm just a girl you know yeah and
going out just with my face with my hair
that that feels for me very amazing to
be treated you know as a human being
because my country I was not actually
and I used to cut my hair just like you
know boys because it's very important
for me to to be the way I am because
sometimes I took I do put myself into
that mm-hmm you know why because I want
to say that it's my I to be Who I am in
my country now I don't have to because I
mean I'm just I don't know how to say
that but you can do whatever you are
very amazing for me just to be Who I am
and just to walk down the street even
during the night I can walk without
anyone attacking me or harassing me or
you know discriminating me though so
it's very amazing for me yeah yeah what
kind of like things have you been
exposed to you like like pizza and likes
like what do you love about like America
like I get the idea stuff I'm with you
on all the idea of stuff but like what
if you like found here that like you
love like a certain type of clothing or
stores well I love everything I love
everything I love in it the nature I
love the land
and I love the people you know I see all
day sometimes I do just sit and still
you know I chew guys and and think with
what are you and what do you think and
how did you you know be like that or you
know act like that so for me it's just
um I love the whole thing yeah yeah I
think well you're not I think I can
truly say like to me that this what
we've done here and connecting you with
you in the first place and the fact that
you're here you know we did this sort of
imaginary thing on skype somehow you
know this thing that either one of us
can explain we somehow did that from you
know 10,000 miles apart or whatever it
is and that you made it and you're here
and I see a light in you and if even if
you have some of that stuff that you
have to work through and all that of
course but I know you're gonna do
amazing things and there's so many
people I want to introduce you to like I
just know so many people that yeah and I
will I will and and we are now friends
and we're gonna stuff and just really
it's beyond inspiring what you've done
and I think the amount of people for all
the ways that Richard Dawkins and sam
and and I on and whoever else affected
you I think that's you know like that
really is you know and and I know the
amount of people that are gonna watch
this and tell me a little bit about just
what you want to do while you're here
and finish your studies and all that
because I think a lot of people are
gonna be reaching out to you yeah
first I was contacted to share my story
on the free thought today and they did
and you know I'm contacted by other
reporters so hopefully that will be done
now I want to start something with my
education I want to finish my masters in
here I want to be a protective you know
person in this society because I do
believe in this society and I want to be
part of it and in the same time I want
to share my story for more you know
further than that
I want to share my thoughts so you can
hear from me I know that I'm a tiny and
I'm not that important but for me it's
very important to share what I have seen
in my country and what I've you know
gone through so now I'm you know I'm
trying to apply for the master's program
and and we'll see from that and well I
know how many people reached out to you
last time you know before even in that
24 hours before before the the death
threats came through we had to take the
video down how many people are reaching
out to and saying how can I help her and
all yeah a lot of people you know
reached out and they tried to connect me
to to you and again and to Richard
Dawkins and sam Harris a lot of them
actually they were very you know very
eager to help in another way and they
were you know contacting even the US
Embassy back in Iraq but a lot of them
were actually reached out by I think our
reporter who helped in my case and
eventually another people I think a
director at that point and ultimately to
the people who got me here so yeah yeah
I'm very grateful to all the people who
supported my case and who even you know
just that you know thought about me I'm
very grateful to that and I can't say no
more and I can't even express it in
words others well you truly never never
owe me any other thanks of anything I
owe you a thanks because this this is
this is this is know I owe you and I owe
all of you my life you know and
everything I went through and and
hopefully I get to see all the people
you know you will yeah I promise you you
and we're gonna do this II will do this
again on cam
but more importantly we're gonna build
something together off-camera and I'm so
excited for your adventure and we're
gonna post some links down below if
there's any ways that people can contact
you know because I know how many people
are gonna reach out to you yeah so thank
you it's always I say thank you you know
I say I thank you
truly from the bottom of my heart and
you know um again I'm very grateful to
and all the people who helped me and and
people who kept me alive and who kept
the help and a bit of passion in me I'm
very grateful to you and thank you for
having me again
[Music]
you